- THE NEXT REVIEW REQUEST
COMES TO US VIA TWITTER
FROM @BUBBLEBATHS.
- AH, AND WHAT WOULD
@BUBBLEBATHS
LIKE TO SEE ME REVIEW?
- THE TWEET SAYS...
- IS THERE--IS THERE MORE
TO THAT, OR IS THAT--
- NO.
"THERE ALL IS ACHING."
- THERE ALL IS--YEAH.
- I HAVE TO ADMIT, I HAVE
NO IDEA WHAT THIS MEANS.
- [laughs] YEAH, WELL,
IT'S GOOD THAT I'M THE REVIEWER
IN SITUATIONS
EXACTLY LIKE THIS
SO THAT I CAN OFFER
UNIQUE INSIGHTS INTO...
"THERE ALL IS ACHING."
AND HERE I GO,
DOING EXACTLY THAT.
GOOD.
- OOH.
- "THERE ALL IS ACHING."
THIS WAS CLEARLY SOME KIND
OF COMPLICATED CODE.
THE BACKWARDS PHRASING WAS LIKE
A COMBINATION OF A ZEN KOAN,
YODA'S CRYPTIC ADVICE, AND ALEX
TREBEK'S QUESTION-ANSWERS.
I DECIDED TO ADOPT
THAT SAME MANNER OF SPEECH
IN ORDER TO HAVE AN AUTHENTIC
"THERE ALL IS ACHING"
EXPERIENCE.
ON RYE TOAST,
B.L.T. ORDERING.
- SAY WHAT?
- UH...MAYONNAISE HAVING,
BUT NOT MUCH TOO, THINK I.
- I'M GONNA GET YOU
A COBB SALAD.
- AH, PRODUCER BATHROOM
IS GOING.
- DID YOU HAVE A STROKE?
- FORREST FINE, I'M FEELING.
- SIRI, STROKE DOCTORS
IN MY AREA.
- ARE YOU EXPERIENCING
ANY MEMORY LOSS?
- FIDDLE I FIT AS I'M FEELING.
"THERE ALL IS ACHING"
WAS PROVING
TO BE A DIFFICULT EXPERIENCE
TO REVIEW.
BUT I WAS HOPEFUL THAT AN EXPERT
IN THE HUMAN BRAIN
COULD HELP MAKE SENSE OF IT.
- WHY ARE YOU TALKING
SO STRANGELY?
- "THERE ALL IS ACHING."
SENSE MAKE TO YOU?
- WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
- THERE ALL IS ACHING.
- HMM.
- MY COMMITMENT
TO "THERE ALL IS ACHING"
HAD APPARENTLY MADE ME
A DANGER TO MYSELF AND OTHERS,
AT LEAST IN THE EYES
OF ONE MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL.
BUT I WAS EAGER TO FOLLOW THIS
EXPERIENCE WHEREVER IT TOOK ME.
[screams]
THERE ALL IS ACHING!
DO NOT UNDERSTAND TOPIC!
NURSE, WHY ARE SMILING?
WHY ARE SMILING, NURSE?
[screams]
[cheerful music]
♪